[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france
24 esta semana la biodiversidad es el
tema central del programa que llega ha
producido desde casa como medida de
prevención ante la pandemia de kobe 19
en los últimos días varios informes nos
recuerdan que la pérdida de diversidad
biológica sigue en aumento por un lado
el fondo mundial para la naturaleza wwf
publicó su informe planeta vivo 2020 en
el concluyente de las casi 4 mil 400
especies monitoreadas de mamíferos
pájaros anfibios reptiles y peces ha
habido un descenso del 68 por ciento en
el tamaño de su población entre 1970 y
2016 y este número es la media a nivel
global sin embargo las cifras varían
mucho dependiendo del lugar del que
hablemos mientras que europa y asia
central han visto un descenso del 24%
américa latina y el caribe registran una
escandalosa disminución de estas
especies del 94 por ciento en la región
el mayor motor de esta desaparición es
la conversión de praderas sabanas
bosques y humedales
en lugares para el pastoreo de ganado o
la agricultura sobre todo en la
producción de soya aceite de palma y
carne de res en el informe de wwf nos
recuerdan que solo existen unas pocas
regiones en el mundo con zonas
totalmente salvajes es decir donde la
huella humana no ha interferido con la
naturaleza estas regiones están sobre
todo en canadá rusia brasil el desierto
del sahara en áfrica y australia una vez
más en el informe hacen la conexión
entre la desaparición de estos hábitats
salvajes y la aparición de enfermedades
infecciosas como el codo y 19 o el ébola
algo que también resalta otro informe
esta vez publicado por la onu el 15 de
septiembre y que llega dos semanas antes
de que se celebre una reunión virtual
con jefes de estado para discutir la
rápida pérdida de biodiversidad el
impacto traumático de la pandemia de
kobe 19 nos deja importantes lecciones
en cuanto a nuestra respuesta a la
crisis de la biodiversidad por un lado
demostró de manera impactante la
relación entre cómo tratamos al mundo de
los seres vivos y la aparición de
enfermedades en humanos y por otro lado
las respuestas de los gobiernos y de las
personas alrededor del mundo han
demostrado la capacidad que tiene la
sociedad para dar pasos antes
impensables que involucran
transformaciones enormes solidaridad y
esfuerzos multilaterales frente a una
amenaza común precisamente en el informe
llamado perspectiva mundial sobre la
diversidad biológica el quinto que
publica la onu se refieren a estos
esfuerzos o acciones interdisciplinares
como la única manera de frenar o incluso
revertir la pérdida de biodiversidad el
reporte asegura que si los esfuerzos que
algunos países e industrias están
haciendo se toman de ejemplo a seguir si
será posible hacer realidad la visión
que tienen las naciones unidas- de poder
vivir en armonía con la naturaleza para
el año 2050 sin embargo si seguimos como
hasta ahora la biodiversidad seguirá en
declive como vemos en la gracia
la tendencia descendente se mantendrá
salvo que implementemos acciones en
varias áreas empezando por un mayor
esfuerzo en conservación y restauración
de ecosistemas una mayor mitigación del
impacto del cambio climático y la
reducción de la contaminación de la
invasión de especies foráneas y de la
sobreexplotación de recursos a estas
acciones habría que sumarle también una
producción de bienes y servicios más
sostenibles en especial de los alimentos
y finalmente reducir el consumo y el
desperdicio de comida
las acciones en cada una de estas áreas
por sí solas no serán efectivas para
cambiar la dirección de la curva
descendente sin embargo la unión de
todas ellas hace que se vean reforzadas
y que la curva no solo deje de bajar
sino que varía su tendencia al alza de
aquí al año 2050 sabemos que tiene que
hacerse que funciona y cómo podemos
alcanzar buenos resultados si
construimos sobre lo que ya se ha
logrado y ponemos a la biodiversidad en
el centro de todas las políticas y
decisiones incluso en los paquetes de
recuperación tras el 19 podremos
asegurar un mejor futuro para nuestras
sociedades y el planeta el informe hace
hincapié en la necesidad de que las
ambiciones de cada país y sus acciones
estén cada vez más alineadas y que estas
últimas se conviertan en algo sistémico
y no tan sólo acciones basadas en
proyectos específicos la necesidad de
invertir más recursos es otra de las
conclusiones del informe sin embargo
muchos países no los tienen para
solventar esto un estudio del instituto
internacional del medioambiente
desarrollo propone un sistema de
intercambio de la deuda externa de
países en desarrollo por programas que
protejan la biodiversidad y luchen
contra el cambio climático aumentando
así su resiliencia antes de la pandemia
las naciones en vías de desarrollo ya
debían unos 8 billones de dólares
el estudio hace un listado de los países
deudores que más se beneficiarían de
este tipo de intercambio dependiendo de
su vulnerabilidad ante el cambio
climático
su riqueza ecosistémica y su nivel de
endeudamiento y estos son caboverde
vietnam honduras kenia nicaragua y papúa
nueva guinea el instituto internacional
del medio ambiente y el desarrollo
sugiere que china país anfitrión de la
próxima cumbre de la biodiversidad que
se iba a celebrar en octubre pero que
fue pospuesta por la pandemia hasta 2021
podría comenzar a implementar este
sistema y dar así ejemplo a otras
naciones proveedoras además de este modo
cumpliría con uno de los objetivos de la
cumbre que es conseguir mayor
financiamiento en pro
la diversidad biológica en el mundo
según los investigadores este sistema es
la respuesta a una crisis triple la de
la deuda la del clima y la de la pérdida
de biodiversidad
es todo por estas semanas sigan con más
medio ambiente en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]